Belgrado aún no se recupera de la
conmoción tras el tiroteo del miércoles
en un colegio
con minutos de silencio ofrendas
florales velas y oraciones cientos de
personas se acercaron hasta el lugar
donde ocurrieron los hechos para honrar
a las víctimas
la sensación abrumadora que tengo es que
esta tragedia es de proporciones mayores
Estos incidentes no son inauditos pero
el horror es indescriptible éramos
conscientes de que nuestra sociedad es
capaz de estas cosas pero la posibilidad
de una escalada así entre niños de
primaria no es algo que preveíamos
el presunto responsable del tiroteo
menor de 13 años y estudiante del mismo
centro permanece bajo custodia al igual
que su padre a quien pertenecían las
armas que portaba sus pruebas
toxicológicas dieron negativo y al ser
menor de 14 años no puede ser procesado
según las leyes serbias por lo que fue
internado en un centro de salud mental
medios locales informaron que se trata
de un estudiante modelo que al parecer
tuvo malas calificaciones y por ello
habría realizado el tiroteo y Manny
Lamento que Serbia ahora esté en la
lista de países donde ocurren estas
cosas tenemos muchas cosas buenas en
nuestro sistema educativo gente
honorable que hace su trabajo por pagos
miserables en condiciones difíciles
los hechos llevaron al gobierno a
anunciar más restricciones para adquirir
armas que no sean de casa una mayor
revisión de los permisos existentes y
una vigilancia más estricta en campos de
tiro y almacenamiento de armas